[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait on it
everybody watching wanna drive still
tickets I'm gonna make a move on me over
it I'm gonna make a move on me Norris
wait on it everybody watching water
clock shows tickets I move on
oh Jesus I'm sorry I had a day and it's
possible I started this party too early
you don't say jacket is it ruined
no not true be told I never wear this
thing probably use a little more high
school experience on it then you should
wear it more often things nicely off her
shoulders Thanks
what's your name
Tandy did you know my dad named me after
his first computer I did not hand of God
how about you I'm a mother's grandfather
and his name was yeah yeah Tyrone
Wow Tyrone just think it's useless so
I'm gonna go get some proper Taos
something a little more absorbing its
orbit it yeah I'd appreciate that
Tyrone hey you made it
emojis hey yeah they hold power come on
my girl appear that much power
okay how much five bucks a cup yeah
one for her please what's wrong my
wallet
hey blog girl
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you